tension hunt man that has had some of
the most badass moments of the entire
series from his clash whatnot but to his
bombardment of self heck he even made us
safer going on in the boo saga now with
his participation in the universal
tournament it's my job to see how strong
he could be based on as many official
sources as I can find
he's Tian Shan hon I'm totally not mark
and this is the power level 2 episode 2
Tian tension on is a human type
earthling 3 I people hybrid who's 46
years old will you take into account the
roughly 311 days he spent dead his
techniques include the four witch's
technique the multi form solar flare and
the key coho or tribum depending on your
dub there are three officially released
power levels for tension hun the first
being 180 the second being 250 and the
third during the seine invasion at 1830
we do however have every reason to
confidently state that he's vastly
stronger than this today so let's take a
closer look he boosted his power level
from 250 to 1830 in one year while
predominantly training under commie with
the other Z warriors
that's over seven times stronger in the
span of one year goku trained with King
Kai for 158 days at ten times Earth's
normal gravity upon arrival at King
Kai's Goku had a part of 416 we have no
reason to suspect that he gained any
more along the way and when he returned
to fight nappa had a power level of over
8,000 which is at almost 20 times
increase during the same invasion Tien
died along with chiaotzu Yamcha and
piccolo he traveled to Kincaid and
record time and trained there alongside
his fellow Z warriors for around 270
days which is almost twice the 158 days
Goku spent there so how did Chan's
training compared to Goku Jean King
Kai's planet well Shion had to acclimate
to the ten times Earth's normal gravity
like Goku did he was there much longer
than Goku he didn't waste time learning
the spirit bomb or the kaio-ken which
removes that don't up your base power
level and he had training partners for a
while
unlike Goku so I think given that Goku
received the 20 times boost in power
tien should receive a little more seeing
as his circumstances gave him every
opportunity to surpass Goku's efforts in
doing so I will acknowledge that Goku is
a Saiyan and grows and strength much
more
surely than tiendas therefore I will
multiply yen's power by only 30 bringing
it to 50 4900 when he gets revived many
months after Goku defeats Frieza it
could be greater or less than this this
is just my estimate given the
information I have found and I'm not
counting the ginyu force altercation on
King Kai's planet because that stops
till now the Android and cell saga is
where things get a little cloudy now one
could look at this quote and think that
it could be indicative that GN and
Yamcha have similar power levels at this
point however this is definitely not
enough to go off of when we look at this
quote he acknowledges the vast gap in
power between both himself and Goku as a
Super Saiyan this is even when Goku
power output as a Super Saiyan is
greatly diminished by the heart virus
looking at all these quotes it's easy to
see at this point there is a clear power
graph established between the Earthlings
and the other fighters TN even goes out
of his way to point it out and this is
pre-cum a fusion piccolo he's referring
to here so things only get worse for
Tianna as this progresses so needless to
say there's some major shade being
thrown Chen's way providing further
evidence the gap is widening and it
continues like this until his encounter
with second form cells in the famous
shin ki Colo scene so given all the
information that we've gathered so far
let's see if we could infer what his
power level could be at this point this
could possibly be a bit tougher than I
thought so after coming to the
conclusion his power level would be in
the neighborhood of 50 4900 once he was
revived on earth TN trained for one year
before arriving to meet trunks who had
killed both tinkled and his son Frieza
once he hears the impending news of the
androids he goes off the train
intensively which he'll sue for an
additional three years during which he
trains on normal gravity he does not
have the tutelage of anyone and his only
sparring partner is chiaotzu so the
question becomes how fast does his power
grow will he was training only with Chan
soo in over eight years tension hunts
power level rises from 180 to 250 with
his motivations largely being to surpass
Goku totaling a 72% increase overall
this was the only reference point I
could find for Winwood improvement
between shout su and TN over an extended
period of time so once he was revived
after Frieza it is known that Chan went
off the train in the mountains with
ciaossu this lasted for four years only
being interrupted by the threat of
freeze of returning and for three of
those years he is treating with great
motivation in preparation for the
Androids having received training from
Kim Chi he has polished his techniques
and training to a degree and I don't
think that's unfair conclusion to draw
given what we have to work with so even
though his time frame for training
wasn't too long I will still give him
the full 72 percent boss by the time the
androids touched down because he was
highly motivated and it is believable
that through training with Connie and
Kim Chi he polished his techniques and
regimen that said he still trained in
solitude and it's been stated that
training in solitude isn't the best
recipe for improvement so with a 72
percent increase that leaves him with a
power level of at most 94 thousand 428
during the events of the cell saga he
does not go up and power level at all at
least not in any substantial or
measurable amount how much training
could he possibly do in 10 days he even
flat out refuses to use the time chamber
saying sorry but I'll pass he's
absolutely not an opponent I could fight
now once the South second comes to a
close Chen says goodbye to everyone will
look out saying that they probably won't
see them ever again himself and shouts
who go to train in the mountains until
being alerted by Super Saiyan 3 Goku's
transformation against majin buu seven
years later again he spends all his time
training in solitude with chiaotzu and
this time it's without the motivation
for surpassing Goku surpassing the
Saiyans or even to defend the earth
against some great threat during the
cell saga he comes to realize that he
will never be a match for piccolo or the
Saiyans ever again
so instead of a 72% boss I will give him
20% for the first time in his adult life
he has no specific goal but he is a
martial artist and he does continue to
train and with that brings us to our
level up to one hundred and thirteen
thousand three hundred and thirteen at
the end of the boom saga in the year 774
during the six years between the Buu
saga and the universe survival arc Tien
has been farming as well as training
with chiaotzu in solitude for this
training I think I'll give him a
maintenance but training is no longer
his sole focus he is briefly fought
beerus and took part in the fight with
the z warriors against Frida's army
leaving him in my estimation with the
power level in the region of 113
thousand three hundred and thirteen by
the time the universe survival Arkell
rolls around but it could be of course
up or down from that this is just a
figure I've made based on what is
available to me Tian could come out of
the woodwork next week and announce
that he's been training intensely for
something and of course then the power
level changes because new information
has come to light
but again similar to Roshi this power
level is not a direct representation of
what change in HoN is capable of putting
out when at maximum power the reason why
characters can fly and shoot glass is
because they're pulling from a finite
pool of key energy the key Koho is the
secret move of the crane school where
Chen Jin hun and Xiao su were trained
this is a hugely destructive technique
the main difference between key blasts
type techniques and the key coho is that
its trajectory cannot be seen one of its
major drawbacks however is its using of
the user's life energy it's even been
said that the move can kill the user but
if we fast-forward to tiens fight with
SEL he had more than just a typical Kiko
hope to sleep he had refined it to
something new the shin Kiko or neo try B
cell definitely wasn't ready for this
new move and couldn't break free due to
how fast Chan was using it it's fair to
say that considering the manga panels
that illustrated the scene
Chien calls cell a little bit of damage
minor at most but it is there therefore
I believe given the information
available here the shin Kiko hos power
output is substantially more than what
yen's power level indicates so whether
or not you are happy with his power
level this move seems to multiply his
power output hundreds of times over
which in technical terms is a metric
crap-ton of power so to say that chan
adds an interesting dynamic to the team
is a bit of an understatement he's one
of the og Dragon Ball characters and
it's great to finally see him get the
spotlight once again tune in next week
when I tackle the next strongest warrior
in universe 7 squad leave a like if you
enjoyed this video leave a comment on
what you think Tien star level could be
and subscribe if you want to see more
this has been the power level series as
always I've been totally not mark thank
you so much for watching
so that was the episode another day
another power level series I really hope
you guys are enjoying these I really
enjoy making them and they're you know
the turnover for these is a bit easier
than making those top 10 now there will
be more top tens in the future obviously
but just I thought this might be a nice
little change a page considering that
you know a lot of you guys seem to like
my review
and stuff so I figured doing a bit more
of an analysis based video might be
interesting so yeah if you guys enjoy
let me know if you guys let me to do
more top tens let me know that as well
remember to like and subscribe I already
said that oh I I recently hit twenty
five thousand subscribers which is just
absolutely insane honestly I never
thought I'd get this far and I'm always
going to keep trying to make better
videos for you guys thank you so much
for your support and I hope you enjoy
these videos thanks guys
you